So i came back.
What ryan doesn't write me a letter saying come out for this festival here in the september festival which he was
organizing. And do things with the kids because it was a lot of stuff going on with it because children born and.
Growing up and so it was a lot of children activity in the community. In the water community.
That's all of us sort of the alternative. And quite sort of. Sane. So we had a. Interconnectedness and.
And still doing you know social interacting you know experimenting. And he came up with the idea of.
Well he had all these pint and he said look at all these pipe nobody wants a pipe the fast is right.
I said oh well just look that is not all ideas of. You know i seen bubbles drifting across the roofs and i said.
Oh yeah. Yeah right. You know because i've never done i've never done yours before they were just on campuses.
But they got but i knew i could do it because of what he'd done things a lot skyll i did things. Anyway.
Now and believe that. And i said.
For him but and also we didn't know any daddy places that i started off with was the places that were already.
Alternative. But i did it. I decided to do it. Really well and.
Try and get everybody sort of the bad joining up the whole.
Do you not the town so did it doesn't exercise the you're not the town. Usually.
And i sort of put a lot of energy i was a little soft again because i thought oh.
Because i thought in terms of whether it's the outrage the global outreach the whole. If thoughts behind.
Connecting up i know this is so idealist i was mad idealist.
And it's
and it's not i don't see myself as a mad ideals i see that we are connected even though people's seanad of action
reaction and. We affect things.
We live on a planet earth which is a living thing in a keeps us alive and we've got to interact with it. And whatever.
And one another to keep it alive. And hopefully it'll get around to that awareness alive are getting.
And so i just got this. You know i had this idea of society. In terms of different.
You know we drift and we come together and we drift apart and you know. This is the house.
How things are and the universe in hundreds. Concept of the universe in terms of of imagery.
Of these orbs that float around because as to how the solar system looks to me there was more information on this.
Just sort of that.
And that's that space that's so developing that same idea did in the early stages i thought this is a great way to do
it sort of having shaped cameras as i do it over the. Facets of to really work the idea.
And i want to go an opportunity so i just put a lot of energy into just going from and and.
Getting these ideas and i did have quite a few i ended up actually doing a whole straight strip.
From one in the town right to the other with that all well with not just with the bubbles drifting
and sort of move from the bubbles in a i've typed it off with the bubbles going off in the fly over the importing which
doesn't exist now. And then i went out to the rainforest and then on to a quiet.
Meditation on to the healing center where they were to sort of came off there.
Just thinking about it and of people letting me do it because they'd. Because i said oh it looks good you know.
They got into the concept.
And what at first it was resistance because it was resistance to some of the people they had
but sort of one of my over by saying what you get into it.
To be part of i did a whole thing on the news i just was the hardest. One because that's was like.
The national party sort of support is there. I ran the news agency and. But. I talked to the. The woman there sort of.
You concept of the taking of having a picture. You know. Up then doing the sunglasses and. All the way to body.
You know happy family. And i had them right up the front. You know right you know.
And i saw right and i thought it was interesting i looked at the quality of words i knew
and how it was the whole place to pretty shoddy up to that the cut of paint would have done it good anyway.
So that's out got away with it actually because the nobody was really doing anything up there. And.
And it was nothing much it was.
You know it's at least i'm giving it a kind of pride and you showed him the idea
and the idea didn't look terribly controversial because it will be interesting to see.
It's always different styles are just sort of developed. I just went along and just.
Tart it up my style basically i worked on. A very simple style. Which was hard it's flat. Color. So all.
Even the three d. Effect was created by. You know. Two tone. To turn a fix. So it's just flat color there's no shading.
It's just actually just flat color. But i mix the colors and i got. So i worked off that.
And it was an easy way to design. So when i get it up. I knew where the. Where the areas of the painting.
So i was just. Was it was a matter of painting areas.
And then you could put in shading another six to work so it was a big job so it kept it is minimal and is easy
and other people can help to paint. In that sort of. Say just feeling. Areas of color. From design.
Well because i have a two year period of that sort of. That that. That strip of.
Of activity of sort of stream of activity that i went overseas. To look at public out in other places.
And you noticed i was actually. Yeah well that actually developed after that when i after finished the mural.
There's a dollar man here that's another. That's a character that developed.
Well actually i'll finish up with this any bubbles because that whole concept was all part of a total concept.
And zanny bubbles actually had i was sort of appearing disappear was sort of. And become a ritual became a ritual.
Perform. Are used in enriching perform i got this as a as a ritual. Leader. A ritual scene a pace or ritual sharman.
And where we did it so i did a series of solstice of into the seasons and. And so. Related to that sort of circular.
And spatial relationship or the other thing here for fire.
Rituals with the community and so was the concentric circles. Of twelve. Balls of fire.
Things like that but i use that that caution became. Of became more than just that it had a cape.
And i did all this illusionary stuff so i developed a whole. Dance theater.
I could do on my own from a injury a little and doing workshops and just doing.
Just dancing with people and developing more vocabulary of movement.
With people over carefully in relating to community dancing. And into rectory and contact and. All that sort of.
The you know this. Developing. You know. Developing processes in. You know our sensory bodily interactions.
And movement. You know ourselves individually. So that was part of that. That was sort of a yogi thing mother had this.
Turtle thing which had spots and i was a focus on the take it out any way i could do these events and expressed my.
Something mind you know. With that. I just use it as a as a springboard to express ideas. And so of good ideas i feel.
It was part of that of. The attention getting attention. And then.
Well don lemon grew out of after that sort of that sort of.
Oh well it was very much involved with healing a process as well. Dance my dance in the movement i was very much.
Became part of my as a healer. In the community.
And that was this whole process of aquarius was developing those skills for healing in actual fact.
And so the community getting together was healing. And. Well traveled overseas with and and.
And my first stop was in los angeles at the world symposium on humanities which johnny allen said.
Attend this is important and vent. And it was that was of the thinkers around the world..
Congregating in different areas around the world. It was the. There was this. The pasadena center was in l.
You know ally and there was the.
The stadium wimbley stadium in in england there was another thing and i was in toronto. Trying to university.
And i had to move around because there was government so they were freaking out towards the end because it looked like.
because it was really challenging the status quo because there was i had a t.v. Link up.
I was going to go on all around. This. And that's when such a lot started to happen satellite t.v.
and I was booked satellite t.v. To be. To link into. Networks around the world about this conference.
And of course governments pull the plug on them. All over this whole thing was sabotaged by governments the actual.
You know the video and interop that i try to do that.
They moved in officials moved in to try and close close down the university there.
And the allied one got off with a lot of difficulty. The wimberley stadium one.
Just got off i don't know they had problems so was the last
and last minute they got a gun because there were problems with. Management the government.
Pulled out was that she was in and she was creating. You know sort of within down the line.
You know why the well supervision was really discussing all these things we're talking about this is the military
complex and the problems in the health and healing in the indigenous peoples.
All these things that really light and to die. That's becoming more and more. You know. You know. Becoming mainstream.
What is my stream now.
That discussion this is the way to go a lot to heal the wounds with with the people that were in this country that work
force or force boy. Military culture. And so imperialist cultures and all that and.
From and the whole culture that was here with us we lighted and. Connected with the earth.
And this awareness was sort of becoming more among people that.
Congregating least spots around the place and the healing and. So i was like the aquarius festival. Ten years after.
But now held in as coffins forums. We think is. Without.
And we had the music gets tight place and the for ritual that was held in a sort of. You know try to be a mainstream.
Event. Was a mainstream a very. And so that. Government people and.
People the ministry rather than the city people have in the field doing it.
And using computers and technology using all of sort of.
You know that state of the asked sort of technology it was a viable.
It's come on the saints i was the age of personal computers.
And just just came on the scene the in there was in haiti nine seventy nine sorry seventy nine was the.
Just before the ickes. And i saw the guy twenty i.d.'s. And i was listening.
This year that we've just gone through with viet nam and it was just and also the.
Nuclear power station in three more along and just blew up a well. Nearly blew up you know so. It was that.
And so there was a big movement towards having this. This these forums.
And so it was to help people similar and i was there was a lot of learning. On my connection with policy larry.
Santee and that's whole the whole idea of. Perma culture. City.
Which he had going then it's a call and i call it cheap prices. So i moved on from frank lloyd wright.
That's another story. And that. And and.
I then took part and then the whole nuclear issue became i became aware helen call it cut was. It was there.
And there was ralph nader. And i spoke to ralph nader. After one of his talks and he said.
Well the best way you can get in touch with people is one to one.
He said talked about all these electronic sin this and that is greit. He said as one to one so.
That's stuck in my mind and. He's right stuck in my he does talk and i will. I pick up the types from.
What was taking place there. And then the nuclear issue was when i got back to a stright avenue q she was.
Was a big issue.
And the aboriginal issue with a lot of things have been america i want to go on this because the whole story in itself
my journey through the whole public. I was involved with the with. No nukes.
No nukes evading three malar not at in new york new york was a whole month of alternative energy.
It was quite progressive.
Like there was an electric buses going around to alternative things that are happening in new york city.
And i was going on and then there was a whole. Plan of action. When you with. The no nukes concerts.
On took place on the. Which was recorded with all these. Stassen there's a whole movement from hollywood.
And around the country coming to new york was sort of. On the road.
Journey and they came to new york with this big mouth of it. Amounts of events.
And that whole technological fare of alternatives. To direct action.
And then there was you know stopping wall street and and. Getting in touch with all the new groups the weapon.
Groups and all that sort the whole thing was the whole link of. The nuclear power. Meeting with the weapons industry.
And how it's. It's really dangerous. You know. Really bad news.
That alone it's the cold war it's creating real real problems. It's just the whole military industry.
And this was going out the whole madness. That we need. Pace and. Not war and you call up nuclear and.
Nuclear stuff was showing its evil rearing its nuclear head with the three mall an accident.
I got a lot of people on the road anyway. So i decided to be part of that. To help with that.
I didn't have the doorman there.
There was sort of happening later on because at that stage i was just they helping or just giving out leaflets and.
I was there was a visitor. I want to came back to australia. There was new combat. And so i was with a sort of help.
Help that i did a flag for. Big aboriginal flag that was up.
Get there was no i mean i he at some paws cathedral so i was there and i had the workshops.
Develop us there was one dance. I was involved dance all the time. Dance and murals.
The whole concert with the bubble still developing. You know with planet earth now going into the pub will. Think.
Who are still developing it and.
So the so then after new combine after that one you know it was direct action and straight.
Event and also observe street theater. You know america. And. And i had in my mind implanted. Certain images.
So i didn't know where i was going there because it all still was into dance and murals
and healing is a really important thing did like the way it was going was really good like that positive.
But it sort of started to dawn on me with. How well i was first of mobs observational direct action on wall street.
That wall street action and. Sort of.
Fifty years since wall street collapse i tried to create the same scenario over with
and you can just stop whole street to stop wall street i have to hold you clean the streets and do no nukes.
And i came back a couple story short. Came back. And i was heard.
Often you can by heard about the little head and it was a healing festival and that and salsas and that.
I was into rituals and. And healing and so forth but. When i got got there.
I heard a story that the ball does what coming in any mean any take of a clock.
To clear these beautiful beats you know. And people meditating and doing you're going to have a strong.
You know what a great importance the aboriginal people. Middle here. And to ryan you just have and the before.
And i was connected with the terrain you and your from. Corresponds i was that the no nukes concerts well.
To run you what's happening as i did was following us around yeah. So i was keyed into that sort of movement.
But you know i haven't been arrested before this was my first arrest of all situation i found like a real head and.
There. I really started out and i was sort of like i was.
I was really got to me i just start saying machinery's as monsters.
And actually got to made by an order is beautiful people and your thirty's and how we oscillate it.
The media slanting that was going on. You know miking us were a bunch of terrorists or how was this whole.
People occupying. An area. And asking questions that hey you know hold it and. You know this.
Let's not sort of devastate this beautiful area this is very rare. Nothing.
And of course we'll put in a position where we had were pitted against these machines and.
The operators of the machines
and the machine for goods are could see these things i would to a long stint of meditation.
After that why i like the first sortie. Well. It was the first sortie. And then i got arrested in that sortie.
Of the forest because of a sort of hide of the trees girl we have is some of the very sensitive to the treason.
Because singing to me. And i'm going to have these so i was.
Something something was going on you know that i want to was but i could hear voices
and things i was sort of spot on i could see the.
Because i did a lot of meditation and yoga and that's that i'm developing that song. And all of a sudden. This sort of.
Other thing was coming to me it is no answer i mean i'm not into sort of. Saying that god spoke to me.
But i was something like that and it's sort of like over such as hearing that crying out there is something you know.
And. And the birds and. You will and. Dead birds on the ground and.
The whole night you was in disarray i could see it i was sitting among it. And we were in there.
And a lot of magic was a lot of magic with the people there
and i mean it was a certain feeling a certain things were happening manifesting in you.
You just felt there was a certain strength.
Even though wolf you were very strong and very powerful people in the bernabeu. Coming up and. And you know we had.
Indigenous people and that was very special because i was becoming aware of the indigenous culture and.
And how you know listen to them and when they come from the primal roots they actually didn't people of. Primal roots.
Go right back of.
Before we became inventors of and trying to think we are god
and change the world that we're actually part of nature who are living with nature back in those days no civilization
driven so i was aware of that sort of connection and
and everything the people of this just every general awareness from that new can by our actions.
Was there and then it was. When you rick it's coming up.
And again graham danson sort of flew and said graeme that and actually had a great influence.
I mean a lot of people have a lot of flak on him but actually he's not here i've got a more here. That's.
Because the after effect he sort of triggered me off.
Another one i mean you'll also you know he sort of triggered of ego type things as well lucky so where did things it
was a good critic i mean he's a critic. You know.
Rights and critics and he stirs up stuff
but he's good because he stirs up this stuff to really bring out the real issues. You know question of you know.
And for change.
So member on the big show was wondering so what are you going to do
but if i say there's all this is happening because i wasn't prepared for us i was still into this thing.
You know i said doing yoga meditation doing circles. You know. All these things are sort of appeasing people sort of.
You know sort of crawling. To say how you know it is that this is the way you guys know it's not so nice seeing up.
We're actually dealing with an evil situation a situation or. People don't want to change fear and well you know.
They try. Intransient. That's it and. And i'll just go through what i want to listen to anything else.
I want to say to that side of it. So i want to shock i mean you know i mean. We needed to do some. Dramatic.
You know i just have to say i'll sit in meditation you know what to do i didn't like to see really try to sort of.
I don't know what to do. At that so when the and then a so we were set up with a recycling fee at the top idea to do.
Actions. In precaution i just came out of jail. And we want to laugh to get back into the area.
And so we were actually.
We would be in court we would've been in trouble so i was always sort of come together in a kind of the concept.
We put on mosques
and we did these actions where we had mass i would know who we work because if they were being identified we would have
been arrested.
So so so we might mosques and seems like a credit to a recycling camp after crime and so
when you going to decide to do that and going to bed and was talking about doing this and all idea of doing a crucifix.
You know i'd like to sort of a crucifix idea of.
Because we only had one way of going to the bache and all the rest was farson. Ogata by police on a white down.
So we sort of created it into that the police pain the the sense. Syrians and.
We set up these crosses and one was it was different was. We had three crosses one.
One was for a woman was a woman on a header. And then one was a hippie and i was aboriginal so we had that sort of.
As a christopher i and i were all.
Built out of the at these cruises we might out of the trees that were white light
and we did this as a one of the actions or memon we sank down by where i was a whole production
and was filmed by boy by d.c. Id say guy am. With his and i'm perfect fit in these nine.
But he filmed it because no media would turn up he was a person they were super right and need to film that.
I remember that action it was really significant. So i set up that camp. To help. And just the this project.
Started it all came together all at once. My guess is this group mind.
It was an aboriginal name to see their two at the dam to see from camera move to middle head.
So the actual that they were. Awful something have but i moved to middle here.
Now didn't see the kick of the just a move to middle head. He saw it. But i know what happened there. Forget.
That i me to mill him. So that there. While in that meditation i had this. Scalpels and.
You know these things came up in and. So and the greed.
And sort of like is a bad greed you know i saw these monsters
and i sort of agree does their own company is a bad grade and that sort of just hit on to me to saudi and of the does.
And the great author does a concept of pull together. Of great guys and coming so. Out of recycled plastic.
And and and cardboard. My greed doesn't come and so i was the first started i was the first stage of that development.
And then. You know that fell apart undeveloped a bit. With piper mashing a crew and then.
As i went they ran actions are developed at caution as part of doing banners and flags
and all the rest of it for actions of development theater pacing
and expression which would be a sort of the shortest ghost. Will appear because we will go doing ghost actions.
With a sort of dark at night would come in and sort of move in and do the sort of.
You know do actions with their costumes sort of an idea and. I was anger. Involved with it at the time.
And now it's changed and i would not anger but actually sort of even developed. As i developed it became sort of.
I mean there's anger buts and that sort of flight.
High catch you see what it's a bad thing we wanted to sort of just get into changing you know.
So that sort of thing is all these are mice mixed reactions go on. But it's. That's not sort of i aim to.
Just slam but it's actually it's sort of to help with enlargement. And martin people for changes.
And so taken around and it's sort of the media pick up on it really well.
I don't connect because i'm really good on a good and good for. Projecting more body.
With the images in whole you know i just i just practiced. Rehearsal every time i do it is another rehearsal.
In a movement. Yeah. So i developed at develop that it was a deliberate development an arc on without us.
Spelling it out just doing it you know just such a strong myself into the into the.
You know help create the theater and then i'm just at that little place myself like. Everything set up in the woods.
To my number. And when i get a rest. I use that as part of the theory like. And just play with the with.
Everything around me to create. Just so that when the. When the where the shot the guy is that sort of.
You get after that. He got these totally images. And they can use it. And just hope the media will use it.
And some do it some don't do it depends and some.
Distorted it i'm going to sing a sing the whole sort of monkey business that goes on with the media different media as
you know some. Distorted. Where they totally were totally ignored it. Or they turned it into something totally.
I did you know. Everybody has their into a totally dark rather than give the full spirit you know what. Really years.
But in others. I was using it but every time i put it in there. It was a plus. Like media is a plus.
Even if they give you bad as to made bad media you still made. I mean it actually rising.
People are being raised about the issue. I mean even i can cause what i. We law and i like. You know these dirty and.
Came. Poor and dull bludging whatever. It's still the issue was about a forest.
Disappearing and toxic weiss going into the system. You know these things and if they really people want to and.
Really want to one of these people on a bad. You know they come up and people come to the. People to come up.
I find out even the journalists that turn up. They get they get mad. They get an earful of what. What we're there.
If they'd. Rejected it. You know on the cutting on the cutting board and then when the cutting.
Wherever it is you know in the editing. Stages. It's you know. On the policy where over the years.
They still got the information that might its way into guys and to the politicians. He said all the lit.
They get it if they listen or not they're getting the information.
So it's been a really good tool to me that direct action. Or ice. Is still good because it does it.
It's sort of you grab them when i say oh well you know i would just listen to them
but with business as usual sort of thing. So they're just sort of holding to ransom.
You know nonviolent to wreck so the other thing is doing nonviolent direct their action.
And that whole development of nonviolent direct action. Of doing things. To make people aware. Without. You know. With.
Without going to war over it. You know. So it was it was an exercise in that itself like the theatrical.
Of theater direct action and. Theater. And the reporting itself an arrestable situations. So the fear bice.
Well i would. Yeah. I observe. I observe people's. Expressions of us and. I mean every time i there.
And i listen to table. And the feedback is a lot of peoples within the movement say.
It's great because it got me involved. A lot of people. I sort of helped a lot of people to be in.
It was a sort of source i placed on the guilt of people like you say.
You know why i work and shoon just go along just forget about it you know and.
You know i was sort of it's you know it's nothing up to us you know your last of us.
Just let it happen it's just you know. On the fans you know you're part of the you part of the problem.
If you do nothing because you're just letting it happen so it's a played on the guilt as well so it was well sort of.
I developed our slogans after to have developed. That sort of.
Other development sort of through great does it was that sort of like. You know.
Do you know just what we're looking at here. This is all for for money.
I mean does now are the reason why they want to knock down this just for money for the retard.
And it's like you know was work. Ensuring the solemn thought that. Came off or.
Offer of a graffiti in adelaide of a pic that. So added that on to it onto the.
Toga and then i rely on you have to see that sort of a piece studying when.
When i was in queensland sort of what happened in stages over a time lapse period. Sort of a couple of years.
From nineteen. I eighty to ninety nine. To the sort of fully established character. And then.
It's costing the earth and that sort of grew out of the franklin.
So for then oh well before that and i was actually before the friends i was.